let me tell you a story about South
Dakota conservative South Dakota has
become the first state in 2017 to pass a
law legalizing the discrimination of
LGBT people I've said it many times
before
yes gay marriage can no longer be banned
at the state level due to that Supreme
Court decision of a couple summers ago
but you can still be fired for being gay
in many states and there are many other
ways to discriminate against the LGBT
community not the least of which is
so-called I know you know what phrase is
coming so-called religious freedom bills
this is exactly what South Dakota's SB
149 does which made it through both the
state Senate and the House of
Representatives both obviously dominated
in South Dakota by Republicans this new
law allows government contracted
organizations to refuse service to LGBT
people including adoption or foster care
services on the basis of the
organization's religious or moral
beliefs and it was signed without
hesitation by the Republican governor
dennis Daugaard Libby Skarin who's the
policy director of the ACLU of South
Dakota said quote this is discriminatory
sorry this discriminatory legislation
takes South Dakota in the wrong
direction and sends the message that our
leaders are more concerned with the
desires of religious agencies than the
rights of individuals and children in
our state in the end this bill was never
about religious freedom it has always
been about allowing private
organizations that discriminate to
receive state contracts and taxpayer
dollars to carry out their religions
missions this law also allows
taxpayer-funded adoption agencies to
discriminate against the gay couple that
wants to adopt but it also gives them
permission to turn down interfaith
couples or single parents or couples in
which one of the prospective parents has
been divorced or anyone else that the
agency says might have a religious
objection even if the people offering to
adopt are in the child's family now
there could be a First Amendment
conflict with the interfaith couples
thing but the real question here Pat is
how many years is South Dakota
to regress here stopping someone from
adopting a child in need because they've
had a divorce in the past what year are
we in they seem to be fighting a losing
battle here because at this time sexual
orientation and gender identity aren't
protected classes and really they should
be and that would require some change in
the federal statute because it's just
like race or religion or veterans status
or age that should be another thing
added and that would have to go through
Congress but maybe there's some hope I
hope so and the key point here is that
we're screwing over children we are
screwing over children to make political
points there are kids in South Dakota's
foster system who need parents and
because of so-called religious freedom
and arbitrary moral codes they might not
get them if you're a four-year-old kid
your parents die for example and you're
put into foster care but there's a
middle-aged lesbian grandmother with a
nice income and a good home for you she
wants to take you and not so fast
because the organization facilitating
the foster care or adoption services is
a right-wing Christian organization that
doesn't like gay and lesbian people back
to the foster care system you go and
unfortunately it's pretty common that
adoption agencies are religious
organizations this law would also allow
agencies to refuse to provide
appropriate medical and mental health
care to LGBT children if the agency has
a quote moral or religious objection to
providing those services and maybe the
most jarring thing under this proposed
law this new law is that agencies
wouldn't lose their licenses if they
force an LGBT child to undergo so-called
conversion therapy to change their
sexual orientation widely debunked and
damaging to kids unfortunately banned in
California tell me one way pad in which
this law benefits kids I can't think of
one way in which kids benefit from this
no in fact it's probably the opposite I
think if there's any hope here it's that
I think Republicans may start changing
course here because even Donald Trump
himself has waived an LGBT flag some
senators and congressmen have come out
in support of gay marriage yeah so maybe
if they're able to do something at the
federal level that which from
what's going on at the state for lack of
a better term yeah I think that it's
going to depend on whether you can raise
money with these right-wing social
positions because no matter what Trump
says no matter what the Supreme Court
does and and regardless of federal
statutes if you can still raise money
because you may be in favor of
increasingly unpopular opinions but they
may still be popular with the people
most likely to donate to your campaign
you're gonna be able to use these
right-wing social positions to continue
raising money you're gonna be more
likely to continue at least taking the
positions publicly even if you don't
believe it in private it seems most of
the money though is on the side in favor
of LGBT issues I don't know maybe less
so that marriage equality has been
passed but now that we have Republicans
in charge the Supreme Court balance
could be changed I think they're going
to keep that going I hope you're right
it remains to be seen and we'll be
tracking it